si precisamente los abogados de la
basquetbolista dicen que no se han
agotado todas las opciones todavía hay
dos instancias judiciales a las que
pueden acudir sin embargo no han dado
Claridad sobre si van a utilizar esas
dos opciones al respecto Jake Sullivan
el asesor nacional de seguridad de
Estados Unidos Pues condenó esta
decisión de parte de la justicia rusa
dijo que esta era una nueva decisión
amañada de parte de la justicia de
Estados Unidos y pidió que se liberara
inmediatamente a estado basquetbolista
de 31 años los abogados de de esta
deportista dicen que aunque tiene sus
altibajos durante estos meses se ha
mantenido se ha mantenido sólida
emocionalmente para enfrentar este
futuro que le espera hay que recordar
que en julio de este año el presidente
Joe vayan le propuso a las autoridades
rusas un intercambio de
le propuso entregar a Víctor un militar
que tiene Estados Unidos a cambio de la
estrella del básquet femenino sin
embargo Rusia pues respondió diciendo
que todavía era muy temprano porque
precisamente este juicio no se había
culminado